قطاع الأفلام، هوليوود وبوليوود
وكل سلسلة القيمة والحجم اللي قاعد يضخ على مستوى الأفلام
بالإضافة إلى الموسيقى، قطاع الألعاب الإلكترونية أكبر منه
بطولة ببجي، يعني صارت حادثة، وزعلت جزء كبير من الجمهور
لخطأ أو لعاطفة جماهيرية
في أحيانًا ضوابط معينة صانع القطاع يصنعها لحفظ هذا الإنسان
رغم أنهم كبار سن وناضجين ومهنيين، فما بالك بفئة عمرية أصغر
ربما يكون عندها هذا المعيار الداخلي أقل
بس أنا ما سمعت منك ولا معيار أنتم شغالين عليه
هذا سقراط من شركة ثمانية
وأنا عمر الجريسي، أستضيف قادة التحول وقادة الأعمال وقادة الرأي
ضيف حلقتنا اليوم هو الأستاذ تركي الفوزان
الرئيس التنفيذي للاتحاد السعودي للرياضات الإلكترونية
القطاع هذا يعيش حراك غير عادي
ومن أهم ملامح هذا الحراك أن تأسيس اتحاد لهذا الحراك
تأسست واحدة من أكبر خمس شركات في صندوق الصناعات العامة
متخصصة في هذا القطاع
قبل أيام سمعنا عن إعلان استضافة كأس العالم للرياضات الإلكترونية
في الرياض في السعودية بدءًا من العام القادم
فاحنا نتكلم على حراك ضخم واستثمارات هائلة
بالنسبة للكثيرين، ويمكن أنا واحد منكم، غير مفهومة
ليش هذا الاهتمام والاستثمار الضخم في قطاع
بالنسبة للكثيرين هو مجرد ألعاب
ففي الحلقة حاولنا نفهم، أيش قيمة هذا القطاع عالميًّا؟
أيش الحراك اللي صاير فيه، وأيش الفرص الموجودة فيه؟
تكلمنا عن ما الذي تم في السعودية من الاتحاد والشركات والوزارات
اللي جزء من منظومة الألعاب والرياضات الإلكترونية
تكلمنا كذلك على أهم البطولات اللي أقيمت والأندية التي تأسست
الأكاديميات والبرامج التدريبية اللي قُدمت خلال الفترة الماضية
بالتأكيد ناقشنا مجموعة من أسئلتكم الثمينة في نهاية الحلقة كالعادة
أسئلة مرتبطة بشكاوى بعض المشاركين في البطولات
من سوء التنظيم، على حد وصفهم
تكلمنا على التَّوجس أو التحفظ من الأثر الصحي والنفسي
لكثرة ممارسة الألعاب الإلكترونية
تكلمنا على التحفظ من مبدأ الاستثمار في شركات ألعاب خارجية
بدون أن نضمن انتقال هذه التقنية، وتوطينها في السعودية
إلى آخر أسئلتكم الثمينة
شكرًا للراعي الرسمي شركة «صفا» وأترككم مع الحوار
حيَّاك الله أبو حصة شرفت ونورتنا
الله يحييك، ويعطيك العافية، وشاكر لك الاستضافة
أنت أبو حصّة، لاعب شطرنج، أيش دخلك في اتحاد الرياضات الإلكترونية؟
صحيح، أنا لعبتي الأساسية هي الشطرنج، وبدايتي كانت في الشطرنج
والشطرنج ما هي بلعبة معروفة عندنا
ويوم من الأيام بالصدفة اكتشفت أن في شيء اسمه الجمعية السعودية للشطرنج
تواصلت مع الجمعية كان فيه إعلان عن بطولة رحت وشاركت
لقيت فيه مجتمع شطرنجي
هذا عام كم؟
هذا في الـ 2013-2014
فشاركت في البطولة، واحتكيت مع المجتمع الشطرنجي
وبدأت أحتك معهم عن قرب
إلى أن رشحوني الزملاء ذاك الوقت أني أكون رئيس
كان اسمها «الجمعية السعودية للشطرنج»
فكانت وجهة نظري أن ممكن أني أفيدكم كمدير، وليس كرئيس
ونبغي رئيس يضيف للجمعية
رشَّحت، الله يذكره بالخير «عثمان القصبي» أن يكون هو الرئيس
وبدأنا الرحلة من هناك
بدأنا باعتماد الشطرنج كلعبة رسمية في السعودية
وبدأنا بالحراك هذا إلى أن...
كم أخذت مدة الاعتماد؟
من أواخر 2014 تأسست أول شيء لجنة الرياضات الذهنية، في 2017
تتكلم على سنتين؟
تقريبًا سنتين
عشان تأسس اللجنة مو اتحاد اللجنة
اللجنة
اللي هي أقل من اتحاد؟
صحيح
ونهاية 2017 اللجنة هذه ترأسها «عثمان القصبي» وكُلفت بإدارتها
نهاية 2017 تم تأسيس اتحادين من رحم اللجنة
راح نجي على الاتحادين هاذين، بس تتكلم على جمعية شطرنج
ليش لما تأسست بشكل رسمي صار اسمها «لجنة الرياضات الذهنية»؟
كان فيه...
أنا جاي من القطاع الخاص
ما عندي أي فكرة عن النظام الحكومي وآلية اتخاذ القرار، والأمور هذه كلها
اجتمعنا مع رئيس هيئة الرياضة هذاك الوقت
كانت رعاية شباب، وللا؟
كانت توها صايرة هيئة الرياضة
الأمير «عبد الله بن مساعد» الله يذكره بالخير
طلبنا أن فيه مجتمع شطرنجي، وفيه حراك شطرنجي
أخذنا عضوية الاتحاد العربي والآسيوي والدولي، واحنا مو رسميين وقتها
فملفنا كان جاهز، ونبغى بس اعتماد، ونبغى مظلة رسمية
ففعلًا رفع للمقام السامي وقتها، وتشكلت لجنة في هيئة الخبراء
أول مرة أدخل على دهاليز عملية اتخاذ القرار، والأمور هذه كلها
وتشكلت لجنة، واجتمعنا أكثر من اجتماع
إلى أن صدرت التوصية بتشكيل...
ما هو اتحاد خاص بالشطرنج، ولكن رياضات ذهنية
وكانت الحساسية في التشكيك في الشطرنج، هل هي حلال أو حرام؟
تجاوزنا هذا الموضوع من خلال لجنة الرياضات الذهنية
فيوم تأسست اللجنة، احتجنا أن نعرّف الرياضات الذهنية
أيش اللي ينزل تحت مظلة الرياضات الذهنية؟
فاكتشفنا أنه الشطرنج والألعاب الذهنية
كألعاب الورقية والرياضيات والخوارزمي، والأمور هذه كلها
بالإضافة إلى الألعاب الإلكترونية
اللي هي كقطاع، الوحيدة اللي تقدر تقول عنها قطاع قابل أن يكون صناعة
فبدانا نفتح خطوط في كل المجالات هذه، وبدأ الحراك من يومها
وبعدين في 2017 أتوقع في فترة معالي تركي آل الشيخ
صحيح
صدر قرار زيادة عدد الاتحادات
كانت حدود اثنين وثلاثين أو واحد وثلاثين، وصارت في الخمسينات
صحيح
أيش كان الجزء اللي لامسكم أنتم؟
أول ما جاء معالي المستشار اتخذ قرار بتأسيس اتحاد خاص بالشطرنج
وتأسيس اتحاد خاص بالرياضات الإلكترونية والذهنية
فاللجنة تحوّلت إلى اتحادين
صحيح
فاتحاد الشطرنج قام بمشروع
ونفس الشيء سنتين دخلتوا لهيئة الخبراء واللجان هذه؟
لا في نفس اليوم
اللي معالي تركي آل الشيخ مسك رئاسة اللجنة الأولمبية
أصدر قرار في نفس اليوم، بصفته رئيس اللجنة الأولمبية
فأسس مجموعة اتحادات اللي أثر علينا بشكل مباشر
اتحاد خاص بالرياضات الإلكترونية والذهنية، واتحاد خاص بالشطرنج
أنت راعي شطرنج بعتهم، ورحت للرياضات الذهنية؟
صحيح، هنا اتخاذ القرار ما كان سهل
أنا فُصلت من وظيفتي، وحُلّت اللجنة اللي أنا كنت موجود فيها
هذه كانت وظيفة بدوام كامل بالنسبة لك؟
صحيح
وقتها كنت مركز على الجانب التجاري
وتجارتي الخاصة بالإضافة إلى هذه الوظيفة
يوم صار القرار هذا أنه تشكيل اتحادين أعدت الزيارة للي أنا أبيه
الشطرنج صحيح أني أحبه وأهواه، وصحيح أنه لعبتي المفضلة
ولكن هل هو مسار مهني مقارنةً بالرياضات الإلكترونية؟
كان الجواب واضح الصناعة والنمو، والأمور هذه كلها
موجودة في الرياضات الإلكترونية
قلت إذا أنا راح أختار مسار مهني، راح أروح مع الرياضات الإلكترونية
واللي ساعدني كثير اجتماعي مع الرئيس سمو الأمير «فيصل بن بندر»
الله يسلمه، سمو الأمير «فيصل» ريحني كثير أول ما قابلته
يوم شفت حجم الشغف والحماس والرؤية الموجودة عنده
كان القرار سهل بالنسبة لي أني أروح مع الرياضات الإلكترونية
فأنت لست من مدرسة اتبع شغفك، وإنما اتبع جيبك
مستقبلك ومسارك المهني يحتِّم عليك
وعندي ممكن تجربة قبل ساعدتني بعملية اتخاذ القرار هذا
فما هو شرط أن الشغف والهواية
ممكن أني أحول شغفي إلى مهنتي
وأخسر مهنتي وهوايتي بنفس الوقت
أبو حصة يمكن احنا سعداء نستضيفك اليوم
لأن موضوع الرياضات الإلكترونية
فيه حديث كثير في الإعلام أو يوصلنا احنا كأشخاص من خارج القطاع
يوصلنا أخبار وأحداث وإعلانات وإطلاقات، ومن أهمها كأس العالم
لكن حجم الوعي والفهم للقطاع محدود جدًّا
وكثير لا يرون أن هذا قطاع حقيقي، هو عبارة عن ألعاب
ليش نضخمها ونحولها إلى اتحاد، ونصرف عليها؟
وفي حجم صرف واستثمار ملياري في هذا القطاع
هذا بالنسبة لكثيرين غير مبرر وغير مفهوم
فهدف هذه الحلقة أن نشرح عن هذا الاتحاد، ونشرح عن القطاع
ونتكلم على أهم ما تحقق الفترة الماضية
لكن خلينا نبدأ بتعريف الرياضات الإلكترونية
تعريف الرياضات الإلكترونية: هي جزء من الألعاب الإلكترونية
فإذا تسمح لي ببدأ بالألعاب الإلكترونية
على أساس ندخل على رياضات الإلكترونية
الألعاب الإلكترونية هي جميع ألعاب الفيديو
التي تمارس من خلال الأجهزة الخاصة بها
سواءً الكمبيوتر أو لوحات المفاتيح أو حتى اللي على الجوال
فأي لعبة إلكترونية تدخل تحت هذه المظلة الكبيرة
وهي صناعة والنظام البيئي الخاص فيها ضخم جدًّا وكبير
الرياضة الإلكترونية تحديدًا هي الجانب المنافسي للألعاب هذه
فإذا صار في لعبة تنافسية
إذا صار في لاعب يلعب ضد لاعب بهدف الفوز
هنا تكون رياضة إلكترونية
الإلكترونية الاحترافية لما يكون في بطولة وفي جائزة
لاعب يلعب ضد لاعب أو فريق يلعب ضد فريق
بهدف الفوز سواءً بميدالية أو بجائزة
ووجود عامل مهم اللي هو الجمهور والمتابعين والمعلقين والمحللين
فكل العناصر الموجودة في أي رياضة تحصلها في هذا الجانب
على أساس كذا سُميت بالرياضات الإلكترونية
أيش تشمل، لما نقول رياضة إلكترونية؟
أيش نوع الألعاب الموجودة تحتها؟
وحاول تخاطب أبعد واحد عن القطاع، لأن أنا ما ألعب
جميل
فما أعرف صراحة، وأتوقع مثلي كثير
زي ما قلت لك، الألعاب أنواع كثيرة وعددها بالآلاف
الرياضات الإلكترونية لا، بالعشرات، وما تتجاوز الـ100
في ألعاب قتالية وألعاب القنص وألعاب كرة قدم
وفي ألعاب استراتيجية
كل الأنواع هذه أو كل شريحة من الشرائح
لها مجموعة ألعاب وجماهيريتها وشعبيتها، تختلف من لعبه لأخرى
أيش أهم من الألعاب؟ عشان نأخذ تصور
أيش اللعبة رقم واحد؟
أكثر الألعاب، مثلًا عندنا على مستوى المنطقة
لعبة الفيفا، كرة قدم واضحة تمامًا
ولكن شعبيتها كرياضة إلكترونية ما هي عالية جدًّا
في ألعاب «الباتل رويال» اللي هي زي ببجي و«فورت نايت»
هذه ألعاب مشهورة جدًّا، وممارسينها كبير جدًّا
الفيفا معروفة اللي هي كرة قدم، وببجي والثانية أيش اسمها؟
ببجي و«فورت نايت»
هذه عبارة عن أيش؟ ألعاب قتالية؟
«الباتل رويال» هذه تكون فردية أو مجموعات يلعبون في خريطة معينة
الخريطة هذه تصغر إلى أن يطلع في الأخير في واحد منتصر
سواءً شخص أو..
المنتصر هو اللي يبقى على قيد الحياة لأنه لازم يقتل الآخرين؟
صحيح
في «الألعاب القتالية» مثل المصارعة والملاكمة
في «ألعاب القنص» وهي ألعاب قتالية وفيها قناص وأسلحة
برضو تكون عن طريق فِرق
وفي «الألعاب الاستراتيجية» أو الـ«موبا»
زي لعبة «ليك اوف ليجيند» ولعبة «دوتا»
هذه برضو أحد الأصناف
وهذا الصنف الأخير عبارة عن أيش، شلون طريقة الفوز فيه؟
أقصد نبسطها عشان أتأكد أن الحلقة ما تكون بس للمختصين
استراتيجية يعني هذا الصنف أنت لازم تفهم اللعبة
أنت تأخذ وقت عشان تعرف اللعبة، وتفهمها، وبعدين تعرف كيف...
بس هي عبارة عن قصة، كل...
هل هي نفس نظام أني أبني مدن وحضارات معينة؟
تقريبًا أنه عندك مجموعة شخصيات، تختار كل شخصية
كل شخصية عندها صفات معينة، واللعب استراتيجي
أنت كفريق تعرف من الأشخاص الموجودين معك
في ناس هجوم وناس دفاع وناس...
هذه أتوقع أبسط طريقة ممكن أشرحها لك
كل هذه ألعاب أبو حصة، ما ودي أقلل من القطاع لأنني من برة القطاع
بس أقصد هذه ألعاب، يعني فجأة اتحاد وبطولات
الناس تلعب من زمان، فليش فجأة صرنا مهتمين نكبر هذه الألعاب؟
جميل، عمر، الله يسلمك
القطاع يواجه تحدي، وهذا التحدي مو بس عندنا في السعودية، تحدي عالمي
أنه متخذي القرار منفصلين تمامًا عن عالم الألعاب الإلكترونية
ما هم فاهمين أيش قاعد يصير في هذا العالم، عالم موازي بالنسبة لهم
اليوم احنا في السعودية، يا ربي لك الحمد
قربنا هذا العالم الموازي، وصرنا نعيشه، وصرنا نقوده عالميًّا
فحجم هذا القطاع ضخم جدًّا، وحجم الفرص الموجودة فيه ضخمة
سولف لي بالأرقام، عشان أقدر أتفاعل معك
اليوم حجم قطاع الألعاب الإلكترونية يتجاوز الـ800 مليار ريال
يعني أيش 800 مليار؟ رقم واضح وكبير بس ما أحد يستوعب
هذا القطاع أكبر من قطاع الأفلام والموسيقى مجتمعة
قطاع الأفلام هوليوود وبوليوود
وكل سلسلة القيمة والحجم اللي يضخ على مستوى الأفلام
بالإضافة إلى الموسيقى، قطاع الألعاب الإلكترونية أكبر منها
هذا عالميًّا
عندنا في السعودية حجم القطاع هذا يتجاوز 5 مليار ريال
الـ5 مليار ريال هذه، أبو عبد الرحمن، كلها تسرب اقتصادي
5 مليار هذه قاعدة تطلع من اقتصادك برة بدون أي تأثير
بدون خلق وظيفة وحدة، وبدون الاستفادة منه بأي شكل من الأشكال
اللي هي عبارة عن مشتريات اللاعبين اللي يلعبوا
100%
5 مليار دولار ولا ريال؟
ريال
ريال، حسنًا
قرابة 6 مليار، وبعدين لما نيجي، ونشخّص الوضع عندنا
بناءً على عدد المستخدمين وعدد الممارسين
الله يسلمك، عدد الممارسين عندنا في السعودية
ثلثين الشعب وثلثين السكان عبارة عن لاعبين
وممارسين للألعاب الإلكترونية
ثلثين؟
ثلثين، 23 مليون 67% من سكان السعودية لاعبين
هذا جانب يبين لك حجم الشريحة
الرقم الثاني عدد الساعات المهول
اللي الناس قاعدة تقضيه على ألعاب الفيديو بشكل عام
عدد مهول من الساعات، فهذا المشهد الموجود الآن
حجم السوق والتدفق الاقتصادي والتسريب الاقتصادي
حجم السوق المحلي الموجود عندنا
كل عدد الساعات هذه هي هدر 100%
فالسؤال كيف نحول عدد الساعات هذه، والطاقات الموجودة هنا
من هدر إلى استثمار؟
جينا باستراتيجية وطنية لمعالجة هذا الموضوع
من عدد الساعات المهول هذا
من أنها تكون هدر إلى أن تكون استثمار من خلال عدة مبادرات وعدة..
ولو راح نتكلم عن المنظومة، وبعدها بدخل على موضوع الاستراتيجية
بس أول شيء بفهم المنظومة، أيش موقعكم أنتم؟
أنتم كاتحاد مرجعكم اللجنة الأولمبية صحيح؟
صحيح
مين اللاعبين الأساسيين في هذا القطاع جنبكم؟
الاتحاد السعودي تحت مظلة اللجنة الأولمبية ووزارة الرياضة
ووزارة الاتصالات تلعب دور أساسي بحكم أن الألعاب الإلكترونية
هذه كلها عبارة عن تكنولوجيا واتصال وخوادم
وزارة الإعلام «جي كام» أو هيئة الإعلام
هم مسؤولين عن التشريعات الخاصة في موضوع الألعاب
فهذول أهم اللاعبين اللي..
وفي موضوع «سافي» اللي هي البطل الوطني في القطاع
صحيح
أيش بالضبط دورها في القصة؟
شركة «سافي» شركة يرأسها سيدي، الله يسلمه
شركة قابضة وطموحة جدًّا من أكبر الشركات على مستوى العالم
تحتها عدة شركات تحاكي كل سلسلة القيمة الخاصة بالألعاب الإلكترونية
وأتذكر تأسيسها له قصة جميلة، ومرتبطة بموضوع الاستراتيجية
فأعطنا قصة الاجتماع اللي ولدت منه «سافي» والاستراتيجية
هذا طال عمرك كان عندنا اجتماع مع سمو سيدي، الله يسلمه
بعد مبادرة لاعبين بلا حدود اللي كانت وقت الجائحة
إذا تسمح لي ممكن أعطي ملامح عن هذه المبادرة تحديدًا
آسف راح نيجي للمبادرة، والألعاب والبطولات اللي نظمتوها
بس موضوع تأسيس الشركة، وإطلاق استراتيجية
يشرح لنا، ويفهمنا، أيش راح يصير بعدها؟
كان عندنا اجتماع مع سمو سيدي، الله يسلمه
وكان عندنا عدة...
كنا نطمح إلى أن القطاع هذا يكون فاعل، ونشوف الفرصة الموجودة فيه
فكان عندنا طلب أن يكون فيه استراتيجية وطنية على مستوى الاتحاد
سمو سيدي، الله يسلمه، وافق
ولكن هذه تكون استراتيجية وطنية على مستوى القطاع
فيه طلب ثاني أو فرصة ثانية لتأسيس شركة خاصة بالألعاب الإلكترونية
بحيث أن نحتاج احنا بطل، زي ما تفضلت، بطل عالمي
للرياضات الإلكترونية تكون على مستوى الاتحاد ومملوكة للاتحاد
سمو سيدي وافق، ولكن أن الشركة هذه تكون من ضمن
ليش تحتاجون شركة أنتم كاتحاد؟
أنت دورك تنظم اللعبة، وتشجعها، وتنظم بطولات
أبو عبد الرحمن، من المشاكل اللي كنا نواجهها في البداية
مثلما أن العامة ما أحد فاهم الرياضات الإلكترونية
حتى الشركات كانت عندها هذه المشكلة، واحنا كان عندنا هذه المشكلة
أي كُرَاسة كانت تطرح من قبل الاتحاد
يجينا عرض غلط ما له دخل في الشيء اللي احنا كنا نبغاه
فكنا نبذل جهد إضافي بأننا نروح نسوي ورش عمل مع الشركات
ومع القطاع الخاص، ونثقفهم في موضوع الرياضات والألعاب الإلكترونية
والنتائج ما كانت قد الطموح، ولا هي قريبة منه
التحدي كان أن فعلًا قطاع يتيم، ما فيه حراك
ما كان في شيء مغري للمستثمرين أنهم يدخلوا في هذا القطاع
لكن مع الحراك الموجود الآن، يا ربي لك الحمد، الوضع مختلف تمامًا
فنتج عن هذا الاجتماع تكليفكم بعمل استراتيجية وطنية
بالتعاون مع الجهات ذات العلاقة، وبتأسيس شركة بس مو تبعكم
التكليف ما جاء في الاتحاد، ولكن احنا كنا جزء داعم
مين اللي كان يقود الاستراتيجية؟
اسمه المكتب الاستراتيجي الوطني بقيادة معالي «فهد تونسي»
والشركة مع صندوق الاستثمارات العامة
واحنا لعبنا دور داعم للفرق وللجهات هذه في رسم الاستراتيجية
دام جبنا طاري الشركة، أيش بالضبط المجالات الستة اللي...
هي خمسة مجالات، أول شيء الألعاب الإلكترونية
فالألعاب الإلكترونية يعني صناعة الألعاب
إذا تسمح لي هنا، أبو عبدالرحمن، صناعة لعبة «بتصنيف عالي»
هو مشروع يأخذ من ثلاث إلى سبع سنوات
اللي هو «التصنيف الأعلى»؟
صحيح
عشان أصنع لعبة توصل للتصنيف الأعلى
أحتاج على الأقل ثلاث سنوات من العمل
صحيح، من ثلاثة إلى سبع سنوات
عشان تصنع لعبة، أنت تحتاج إلى استيديو
تأسيس الاستيديو يأخذ من سنة إلى سنة ونصف
وبناء الفريق والأمور اللي تحتاجها
فهذا خط خاص بصناعة الألعاب
احنا نصير نبرمجها، ونبتكر شخصياتها، ونصنع الملكية الفكرية حقتها كاملة
100%
هذا أول خط في شركة «سافي» والثاني؟
الخط الثاني في الرياضات الإلكترونية
شركات تنظيم بطولات الرياضات الإلكترونية رائدة
ومن هنا تم الاستحواذ على شركة «إي.أف.جي»
اللي هي أكبر شركة رياضات إلكترونية على المستوى العالم
وهذه أيش أصلها؟
هذه شركة ألمانية
مختصَّة في تنظيم البطولات؟
هي مكتبها الرئيسي في ألمانيا، ولكنها شركة عالمية
عندها بطولات على مستوى العالم كله
فتم الاستحواذ عليها من قبل «سافي»؟
تم الاستحواذ عليها
تخدم الخطة الثاني اللي هو تنظيم البطولات؟
100%
الخط الثالث هي البنية التحتية، نتكلم عن مراكز للألعاب الإلكترونية
نتكلم عن خوادم، وبجي للخوادم، والأمور الخاصة فيها
وبعدين شركات عبارة عن دعم مالي واستثمار بحت
شركة «بي.سي.ستايل» استثمار جريء
تستثمر في الشركات الصغيرة والمتوسطة، وتدعم رائدي الأعمال
والشركة الخامسة عبارة عن صندوق يستثمر في الشركات العالمية
«بالتصنيف الأعلى» شراكات استراتيجية
كل الاستثمارات هذه تكون استراتيجية نستثمر من خلالها
لازم عضوية مجلس إدارة، وفي توطين للعبة، وشغلات استراتيجية كثيرة
الخط الأخير هو اللي صار من خلاله موضوع استحواذ
على حصة في «نينتندو» وفي ألعاب أخرى؟
صحيح
هذه المجالات الخمسة لشركة «سافي»
نرجع الآن للاتحاد، أيش الاستراتيجية اللي طلعتوا فيها بعد هذا العمل؟
وين راح تروحون؟ عشان بعدها  نتكلم على، أيش حققتوا؟
استراتيجية الاتحاد هي جزء من الاستراتيجية الوطنية
الاتحاد هو أحد الأدوات الخاصة بالاستراتيجية الوطنية
2018 و2019 كان المشهد بطولات يتيمة وبسيطة
نختبر السوق ونجرب مدى الإقبال والألعاب، والأمور هذه كلها
وقت الجائحة طلعنا بمبادرة «لاعبون بلا حدود»
كلنا نذكر الجائحة والظروف اللي مرت كان في فكرة أننا نطلع بمبادرة
أنه نرصد جائزة قيمتها 10 مليون دولار
يشارك فيها أفضل اللاعبين على مستوى العالم
نصنع محتوى نرتبط مع الناس، ولاقت إقبال كبير جدًّا
ميسي وكريستيانو كانوا جزء من هذا المحتوى، ومئات الملايين...
كيف كانوا جزء من المحتوى؟
ميسي وكريستيانو لكل لعبة، احنا سوينا ستة بطولات
بأبطال العالم لكل لعبة كانوا جزء من...
ظنيت هم بنفسهم كانوا يلعبون أو شيء زي كذا
لا، أبطال العالم، وكلٌ بحسبه في كل الألعاب
كانوا جزء من هذه المشاهدات كانت جدًّا عالية
الإقبال كان جدًّا شديد عليها
بعدها بدأ ينضج القطاع طلعنا بمبادرة «الدوري السعودي الإلكتروني»
هذا أهم منتج موجود عندنا اللي يحرك الأندية السعودية
واحنا كاتحاد، أبو عبد الرحمن، الهدف الأسمى للاتحاد
سواءً اتحاد الرياضات الإلكترونية أو أي اتحاد
الهدف الأسمى له أن يحقق الميداليات الذهبية
ويشرف السعودية في المحافل الدولية
فصناعة منتخب هو الهدف الأساسي لوجود الاتحاد
رحلة صناعة المنتخب طويلة جدًّا لازم يكون عندك دوري
ولازم يكون عندك أكاديميات وتدريب
واحدة من المنتجات الموجودة عندنا أو البطولات الخاصة
دوري خاص بالجامعات
عندنا دوري خاص، البطولات المجتمعية كثيرة جدًّا
فالحراك اللي قاعد يصير على مستوى «اي سبورت» في السعودية جدًّا عالي
تكاد تخلو أي عطلة نهاية الأسبوع أو أي أسبوع من بطولة
سواءً على مستوى مجتمعي أو جامعات أو على مستوى لعيبين النخبة
اللي هو الدور السعودي الإلكتروني
كلام جدًّا جميل، لكن لما أشوف ملايين وجوائز وتحفيز
وأرجع اشوف كم اللي شاركوا في الدوري السعودي
وكم اللي شاركوا في بطولة السعودية
ألاقيهم بحدود 330 لاعب فقط، أنا ظنيت أني بشوف آلاف وملايين
ليش الأرقام ما تعكس توقعاتي، أيش الغلط؟
الدوري السعودي، أبو عبد الرحمن
هو للاعبين المحترفين والأندية المحترفة
عشان تضمن لنفسك مقعد في الدوري السعودي في تصفيات تأهيلية
والتصفيات التأهيلية هي اللي فيها الآلاف وعشرات الآلاف
التصفيات التأهيلية مفتوحة، أي نادي يقدر يشارك
اليوم عدد الأندية المسجلين عندنا الفاعلين أكثر من 100 نادي
100 نادي مسجل اليوم في الاتحاد؟
صحيح، أكثر من 3000 لاعب محترف
هذول لاعبين مسجلين، وعندهم عقود مع أندية سعودية
لكن كدوري هذا دوري محترفين ما يشارك فيه إلا اللاعبين المحترفين
حتى لو كان العدد أكبر
تلقاهم في دوري الدرجة الثانية أو دوري الدرجة الثالثة
ما دام تكلمنا عن الدوري ممكن تشرح لي فكرة الدوري
وشلون المشاركة فيه، والجوائز والتصنيفات؟
ممتاز، الدوري هو دوري...
هو أهم منتج عندكم المفروض صح كاتحاد؟
بالضبط، هو الدوري الأساسي
وأهم ميزة له أنه يأهل إلى موسم «القيمرز»، ويؤهل إلى كأس العالم
الدوري، الله يسلمك، هي تصفيات مفتوحة الكل يقدر يشارك
لازم تكون نادي مسجل في الاتحاد، ويكون عندك لاعبين
فالخطوة الأولى أني أسس نادي، وأسجل في الاتحاد
صحيح
أجمع اللَّعيبة
رحلة النادي، نأخذها كرحلة
ياريت
النادي لازم يسجل، كل الأندية عبارة عن شركات
كلهم ريادين أعمال، كلهم ناشئين
يسجل في الاتحاد، ويتعاقد مع لاعبين يسجل في بطولة معينة
اللي هي التصفيات التأهيلية
هذه تصفيات مناطقية ولا مفتوحة؟
هذه عن طريق الإنترنت، فنستقبل أي عدد ممكن
إذا تأهلت من خلال البطولة التأهيلية
غالبًا يطلع عندنا من ستة عشر إلى ستة أفرقة بناءً على اللعبة
في ألعاب نستقبل إلى ستة عشر، وفي ألعاب نكتفي بستة
بحكم طبيعة اللعبة نفسها
فهذه اللعبة إذا وصلت إلى الدوري السعودي الإلكتروني
تبدأ التصفيات الخاصة بالدوري السعودي الإلكتروني
إلى أن توصل للمراحل النهائية، وبعدين الكأس
أنا كأني فهمت منك، بس عشان اللي ما هو معانا في القطاع
أنها هي أقرب الأولمبيات من الدوري اللي احنا متعودين عليه
دوري كرة القدم مثلًا احنا ما نتكلم على شيء يشبه دوري «روشن» لعبة واحدة
احنا نتكلم على الدوري السعودي هو الأولمبيات ففيه أكثر من لعبة
الدوري السعودي عندنا السنة اللي راحت نظمنا ستة ألعاب
السنة هذه نظمنا فيه سبعة ألعاب
فعلًا الدوري السعودي ما هو لعبة واحدة، هو عدة ألعاب
فأنا نادي سقراط للرياضات الإلكترونية
المفترض أنني أستقطب لعيبة شاطرين في هذه الألعاب السبعة، صح؟
صحيح
عشان لما اجي أتنافس معكم
النتيجة النهائية حقتي في مرحلة التصفيات
هي مجموع النقاط اللي جمعوها لعيبتي في كل هذه الألعاب السبعة المختلفة
كل لعبة...، خلينا نضرب مثال بالرياضة العادية
من سباحة أو طائرة أو فروسية أو كرة قدم
في كل لعبة في كأس وفي بطولة
وفيه كأس على مستوى مجموع نقاطك على كل الألعاب
نفس الشيء على مستوى كأس العالم أو موسم «القيمرز»
هذه الفكرة أنك تشارك في كل البطولات
في كل الألعاب المختلفة، وتحصد نقاط من كل لعبة
واللي يحصد أعلى نقاط ممكنة هو الفائز في..
كم عدد الأندية اللي تشارك في الدوري؟
الدور السعودي؟
نعم
من ستة إلى ستة عشر هذا الدوري على حسب اللعبة
والتصفيات التأهيلية تتجاوز الثمانين، وتوصل إلى 100
هذا واضح
أيش أهم الأرقام اللي نقدر نحكي عنها كنتائج وكمخرجات للدوري الموسم هذا؟
أنتم موسمكم متى يبدأ، ومتى ينتهي؟
من بداية فبراير إلى نهاية السنة
إلى نهاية السنة؟
صحيح
فالموسم لسه ما انتهى؟
الموسم لسه ما انتهى
طيب، نأخذ العام الماضي، أيش أهم الأرقام؟
كمشاهدات ومشاركات وجوائز بس عشان نفهم، أيش قاعد يصير؟
اليوم ستة بطولات عبارة عن موسمين، موسم قبل الصيف وموسم بعده
فترة موسم «القيمرز» هي فترة توقف
عدد الأندية اللي شاركت أكثر من 100 نادي
عدد اللاعبين تجاوز الـ3000 لاعب
لاعب والمشاركات الخارجية أكثر من عشرين مشاركة لفِرَق سعودية
كل ناشر له لعبة وبطولته الخاصة فيه
اللي هي نعتبرها كأس العالم أو بطولة العالم الخاصة بالناشر نفسه
هذه المشاركات اللي فيها
على مستوى الرياضات الإلكترونية في قصص نجاح، إذا تسمح لي
ياريت
أبو عبد الرحمن بضرب مثال على «مساعد الدوسري»
قصة ملهمة ما هو على مستوى السعودية بل على مستوى العالم
«مساعد» بدأ مشواره لاعب هاوي بعدين لاعب محترف
بدأ يشارك، وينافس على بطولات عالمية
وفاز بلقب بطل العالم للعبة الفيفا
كمل مشواره، والتحق بريادة الأعمال أسس، وقاد فريق اسمه «فالكون»
واليوم فريق «فالكون» من أهم الفرق على مستوى العالم
ومن أهم الفرق على مستوى كأس العالم
أو موسم «القيمرز» اللي حقق نتائج مبهرة
في فريق ثاني فريق «تويستد مايند» شباب سعوديين
رياديي أعمال مركزين في عالم الرياضات الإلكترونية
أسسوا الفريق، وركزوا وشاركوا، وتأهلوا في أكثر من فريق
على أكثر من لعبة لموسم «القيمرز»
وبطل موسم «القيمرز» السنة هذه، فريق سعودي
اللي هي أشبه بالبطولة العالمية، صح؟
اللي هي الأولمبيات اللي تفضلت، أنت شرحتها
أخذوا وشاركوا في أكبر عدد ممكن من البطولات
وجمعوا نقاط في كل لعبة
الفريق الأعلى فريق سعودي فريق «تويستد مايند» شيء نفتخر فيه جدًّا
فعلى مستوى الرياضات الإلكترونية
اليوم الأساس اللي احنا وصلنا له جدًّا ممتاز والطموح أعلى
وما دام ضربت أمثلة بالأندية
كان فيه أحد أسئلة أصدقائنا أن هل هي تسوِّى؟
هل هي مصدر رزق؟ هل هي وظيفة؟
إذا أخذنا الأندية كمثال
وقلت لنا، أيش أهم مصادر دخلهم، وأهم مصروفاتهم؟
عشان الواحد يقدر يتخيل، هل هي مجدية أم لا؟
أهم مصدرين لدخل الأندية هي الرعايات والجوائز المالية
الرعايات أنت وشطارتك كنادي، الجوائز من عندكم أنتم من الاتحاد
سواءً من عندي أو من البطولات الثانية اللي يشارك فيها النادي
وقوته على تحقيق المراكز أنها ترجع لهم الجائزة، هذا أهم مصدرين
المصاريف غالبًا تكون للتعاقد مع اللاعبين وتكلفتهم
بالإضافة إلى الجهاز الإداري
في تعاقد مع اللاعبين في عقود وراتب لهذا اللاعب مقابل أنه يلعب
صحيح، اليوم 3000 لاعب، الله يسلمك، في السعودية
هذول كلهم لاعبين عندهم عقود
احنا ما نقدر نحسب اللاعب كمحترف، وهو ما عنده عقد
لازم يكون عنده عقد ومع نادي
راتب شهري؟
وراتب شهري
نتكلم على كم الرواتب؟
الحد الأدنى السعودي اللي هو 3500 أو 4000
نسبة من الجائزة، عاد أنت وقوة اللاعب هي اللي...
أيش أعلى عقد عندكم؟
اللاعبين عينهم دائمًا على الجائزة الشاطرين فالتفاوض ما هو على الراتب
التفاوض على الراتب ما راح يوصل إلى أرقام عالية
يوصلون إلى عشرة، ويوصلون إلى عشرين وأحيانًا ثلاثين
بس الملايين هي موجودة في الجوائز
فاللاعب المحترف ما يفاوض على الراتب قد ما يفاوض على نسبتة من الجائزة
من الجائزة بس ما عندك رقم لأعلى لاعب السعودي كدخل
ما يحضرني الآن
هذا كان الدوري فيه أنتم عندكم بطولة أخرى برضو
اللي هي كأس السعودية لكرة القدم الإلكترونية
هذا غير الدوري السعودي، صح؟
صحيح
هذا أنتم نظمتوه بعد؟
سولف لنا عنه
هذه، الله يسلمك، نسخة افتراضية
آسف بس عشان نقفل الدوري السعودي، جائزة المركز الأول كم؟
500 ألف
500 ألف؟
لكل لعبة
لكل لعبة؟
لكل لعبة 500 ألف
فأنت تقريبًا عندك سبعة ألعاب، فثلاثة مليون ونصف
صحيح
هذا الدوري السعودي، أيش فرق عن كأس المملكة؟
هذا طال عمرك، الدوري الإلكتروني لكرة القدم
نسخة افتراضية أو نسخة ألكترونية محاكاة للدوري السعودي لكرة القدم
فاحنا أسسنا رابطة تحاكي رابطة الدوري السعودي
فيها كل الأندية ممثلين لها كل نادي من الأندية الهلال والنصر وغيره
يتعاقدون مع لاعب محترف يمثلهم في الدوري الإلكتروني لكرة القدم
الدوري الإلكتروني لكرة القدم
هذا عالم موازي للدوري الفعلي
صحيح
وكل نادي هو يملك المشاركة باسمه من خلال لاعب هو يختاره
هذه كم صار لها؟
هذه بدأناها في 2019
وسنويًّا تسوونها؟
سنويًّا
من بطل آخر نسخة؟
تصدق ما يحضرني، بس مو بالهلال
مو الهلال، ما أدري ليش أنت متحمس تقول المعلومة هذه
هل فيها جوائز، وللا ما فيها؟
هذه فيها جزائز كمان
ما تعرف كم الرقم؟
لا
دوري الجامعات هذا لو تسولفنا عنه، أيش فرقه عن...؟
ممتاز، دوري الجامعات من أكثر البطولات اللطيفة
نتواصل مع الزملاء في اتحاد الجامعات
فكرة الدوري هذا أنه نسوي مسابقة بين الجامعات
مين يستضيف دوري الجامعات للرياضات الإلكترونية؟
فكل جامعة تقدم مقترحها، وطريقتها في العرض، وتشكل لجنة
وتفوز جامعة معينة
على سبيل المثال السنة الماضية كانت جامعة «الخرج»
هي اللي فازت في هذا الموضوع
فكل الطلاب هم يكونون جزء من تنظيم البطولة هذه
كل الجامعات يسوون تصفيات
ويؤهلون لاعبين وفرق تمثلهم في الألعاب المختلفة
والجامعة المستضيفة تنظم البطولة لمدة ثلاثة أو أربعة أيام أو أسبوع
على حسب البطولة ووقتها
وعندكم نسختين للأولاد، ونسخة للبنات، صح؟
صحيح
لاحظتوا في إقبال من البنات وللا ما فيه؟
الظاهر يمثلون 18% فقط من المحترفين في القطاع
صحيح، أبو عبد الرحمن على مستوى الألعاب الإلكترونية
تقريبًا نسبة مشاركة المرأة 50% أو 48% هو الرقم الدقيق
كلعب بشكل عام
على مستوى الرياضات الإلكترونية
طبعًا هذا الرقم أقل بكثير كمشاركة المرأة في حدود 20%
ولكن عندنا في السعودية مشاركة المرأة في الـ«إي سبورت»
أكثر من المتوسط العالمي
يعني كم، ولا ما عندك رقم؟
احنا في حدود العشرين، عالميًّا ثلاثة عشر أو أربعة عشر
احنا نعتبر أعلى من متوسط العالم
أتوقع نوصل الحين إلى البطولة الأهم من الفترة الماضية
أو الحدث الأهم اللي أنتم اشتغلتوا عليه اللي هو موسم «القيمرز»
هذا يعتبر أكبر منتجاتكم الفترة الماضية
صحيح
سولف لنا عنه، كيف بدأت الفكرة، وأيش الأثر؟
موسم «القيمرز» وحدة من المبادرات الخاصة بالاستراتيجية
أننا نستضيف، وننفذ، ونصدر أكبر البطولات
فجاءت الفكرة أن يصير في موسم خاص في «القيمرز»
وجاءت الفكرة أن، كيف نفعل مدينة الرياض وقت الصيف؟
فالألعاب الإلكترونية و الـ«إي سبورت» تحديدًا
هي دائمًا راح تكون فعليات في أماكن مغطاة، ومكيفة والألعاب الإلكترونية
فجاءت الفكرة أنه نقيم الحدث هذا على فصل الصيف لعدة بطولات
ونستقطب فيها أكبر عدد ممكن من أفضل اللاعبين
أول مبادرة أو أول موسم كان عام 2022 والسنة هذه كان عام 2023
أهم الأرقام اللي صارت، أبو عبد الرحمن، على مستوى الموسم
عدد المشاهدات تجاوز مليار و300 مليون للجنسيين
مليار و 300 مليون؟
مليار و 300 مليون
المشاهدات للموسم هذا فقط، ولا تراكمي؟
لا، الموسم هذا فقط
عدد الجنسيات التي شاركت أكثر من ثمانين جنسية
عدد اللغات التي بثينا فيها سبعة وثلاثين لغة
تقريبًا استهدفنا كل دول العالم
عدد اللاعبين اللي شاركوا حدود 3000
كم نادي؟
حدود 300 نادي كلهم كانوا جزء من موسم «القيمرز»
كم منهم من أندية السعودية تقريبًا؟ أنا بستوعب كم اللي جاء من برَّة
بحدود ستة أندية سعودية
بحدود...، كم قلت 300؟
يعني 5% كان نصيب اللاعب السعودي والفرق السعودية
طبعًا بألعاب مختلفة
الأندية السعودية شاركت بأكثر من لعبة
بينما الأندية الأجنبية ما شاركت في كل الألعاب
فمليار 300 مليون و800 جنسية
الزوار 2.6 مليون زائر لموسم «القيمرز»
وين كان الموسم؟
في البوليفارد في الرياض
يا أبو عبد الرحمن، إذا هذا ما هو كأس العالم، أيش هو كأس العالم؟
كل الأرقام تجاوزت توقعاتنا
كان التحدي بالنسبة لنا كبير جدًّا على مستوى التنفيذ
فصل الصيف بالرياض ما هو أجمل وقت
غريب، ليش اخترتوا الصيف؟
جزء من مسؤوليتنا والأهداف اللي علينا تفعيل الرياض في فصل الصيف
فيا ربي لك الحمد، على أن كان الوقت...، يعني ما كان من أفضل الأوقات
على أنه كانت التحديات مرة كبيرة، السقف كان جدًّا عالي
لكن، يا ربي لك الحمد، كان نجاح
وهذا ما هو كلامنا، هذا كلام الناس اللي شاركوا معنا في الموسم
اللاعبين والمنظمين تجربتهم كانت رائعة
الصحفيين والإعلاميين تجربتهم كانت رائعة
وعلى سبيل المثال أقول قصة
كثير من الأندية كانت تتواصل معنا تبغى تعسكر فى الرياض
للتحضير لبطولة ثانية فى دولة ثانية
كثير من الأندية تواصلوا معنا، قالوا احنا نبغى نفتح مكتب في الرياض
ونبغى نكون نادي سعودي
ونبغى نكون جزء من الدوري السعودي الإلكتروني
كثير من الحراك هذا
هل النظام يسمح أن يصير في نادي غير سعودي في الدوري؟
أنا نظامي الأندية اللي تشارك سعودية فإذا هو سجل تجاري سعودي
بس إلى الآن ما بعد أحد سوى هذا الشيء؟
إلى الآن ما وصلنا هذه المرحلة
موسم «القيمرز» على الرغم من كلامك الجميل عنه
أنا مبسوط وفخور باللي قاعدين تسوونه، بس ليش ما نحس فيه؟
ليش ما هو قاعد يوصل صدى؟
تتكلم عن بطولة كأس عالم، بس حتى ما سمعت خبر واحد في الإعلام
أقصد الإعلام الدولي أو الأجنبي عن هذا الحدث
هل لأنه مجتمع مغلق؟
ولا لأنه احنا نضخم الحدث بس هو فعليًّا ما هو ضخم؟
ليش ما أحس أنه سوى صدى؟
الله يسلمك، جمهور الألعاب الإلكترونية
وجمهور ألعاب الفيديو بشكل عام جمهور ضخم، ما فيه شك
ولكن أي شخص برَّة هذه الدائرة دائمًا يكون غير مرتبط
ما هو فاهم اللي قاعد يصير حتى لو طلعت أخبار معينة
طبعًا، هذا جزء من مسؤوليتنا أنه نتواصل، ونشرح القطاع بشكل أكبر
لكن اللي صار من خلال الإعلان الخاص بكأس العالم
كان أثره جدًّا إيجابي وجدًّا كبير على مستوى المجتمع
ألعاب الفيديو كان صداها إيجابي جدًّا
وحسيناها احنا بشكل مباشر من خلال أن الرعاة بدأوا يتواصلون معنا
ومستثمرين بدأوا يتواصلون معنا، والأندية بدأت تتواصل معنا
وأهم اللاعبين في البيئة الخاصة بكأس العالم أو سلسلة القيمة
كانوا جزء من الإطلاق، فأهم الأندية كانوا جزء منها
وأهم الناشرين والألعاب كانوا جزء من الإطلاق
فأثرها كان جدًّا كبير وإيجابي ومتفائلين بالسنة الجاية بشكل جدًّا كبير
ما دامك جبت طاري كأس العالم، أيش فرقه عن موسم «القيمرز»؟
وين كان يقام هو، عند مين الكأس هذا؟
كأس العالم هو تحول لـ«القيمرز إيد» والتقييم الخاص فيه
بعد النجاحات اللي حصلت على مستوى «القيمرز إيد»
تأسس أو تحول إلى مشروع كأس العالم
كيف تحول؟
هذه عادة عند الفيفا هو اللي ينظم أشياء زي كذا؟
ممتاز
شلون قررتوا تسووا مؤسسة؟
القطاع، أبو عبد الرحمن، شوي معقد
فيفا، زي ما تفضلت، كرة قدم هو اتحاد دولي لكرة القدم
تنظيم بطولة خاصة بكرة القدم
تحتاج فريقين ملعب وكرة، وانتهينا
لما نتكلم عن الرياضات الإلكترونية فيه لاعب مهم وأساسي
اللي هو ناشر اللعبة اللي يملك اللعبة هذه
فكل بطولة تقام لازم يكون فيه ترخيص ومواءمة مع مالك اللعبة نفسها
فالمختلف عن أي رياضة ثانية
أنه هذه اللعبة لها مالك وفيه حقوق نشر، ولازم تتواصل معه
على مستوى الأندية في الرياضات الإلكتروني هي شركات
الأندية على مستوى كرة القدم فيه منتخبات، وفيه أندية تابعة للدولة
على مستوى الرياضات الإلكترونية الأندية عبارة عن شركات
شركات تلقاها متعددة الجنسيات
فالمشهد مختلف تمامًا عن مشهد الرياضة زي كرة القدم
في طبيعة الحال، فرصة أن يكون في شيء يوحد الجهود هذه كلها مع بعض
صناع الألعاب يكونوا موجودين الأندية تكون موجودة
ونصنع أكبر «ملكية فكرية» ممكنة وأكبر بطولة ممكنة
احنا استغلينا هذه الفجوة، وعدم وجود أي مظلة رسمية جامعة لكل هذه الجهود
السعودية بادرت، واستغلت الفرصة، وسوت هذا كأس العالم
اللي هو تملكه مؤسسة غير ربحية
بالضبط، الريادة الموجودة، الله يسلمك
قطاع الألعاب الإلكترونية عمره أربعين سنة
الرياضات الإلكترونية ما بدأت تطلع إلا من عشرين سنة
قبل عشرة سنوات بدأت تنضج الألعاب الإلكترونية شوي
فالريادة السعودية اليوم قيادة سمو سيدي، الله يسلمه
ما هي بس على مستوى المحلي لكن في هذا القطاع الريادة عالمية
كأس العالم اليوم موجود في السعودية، واحنا اللي نقود المشهد هذا
السنة الجاية أول نسخة؟
صحيح
أنتم المسؤولين عن تنظيمها؟
من يملك كأس العالم؟
كأس العالم يملكه جهاز اسمه تم الإعلان عنه
«مؤسسة كأس العالم الغير ربحية»
«كأس العالم للرياضات الإلكترونية الغير ربحية»
فهذا الجهاز هو المسؤول عن ملكية وتنفيذ كأس العالم
وأنتم أيش دوركم؟
احنا دورنا داعم الاتحاد هذه منظمة مسؤولة عن كأس العالم
الاتحاد أنا وضعي الأساسي هو تشريف السعودية في المحافل الدولية
هذا محفل دولي مهم
أيش تعرف عن نسخة القادمة، متى بتكون؟
هي امتداد لموسم «القيمرز»
راح تكون في الصيف في الرياض شهر سبعة وثمانية
عدد الألعاب راح يزيد عن السنة هذه
التصفيات والمنافسة راح تكون أشد بالكثير
كم الجائزة؟
الجائزة السنة هذه كانت 45 مليار دولار
45 مليون قصدك؟
45 مليون دولار السنة الجاية إلى الآن، ما أعلن عنها
45 مليون دولار، هذه قسمت على كم فريق؟
تقريبًا على 100 فريق
100 فريق اللي شارك فيه
لا بس أقصد اللي أخذوا جوائز، وللا هي تصاعدية؟
اللي أخذوا نصيب الأسد؟
أي
لا، تقريبًا الكل شارك فيها
نصيب الأسد راح يكون لأعلى 10% احنا نتكلم عن عشرين إلى ثلاثين فريق
عشرين إلى ثلاثين فريق
هل لكم دخل في المؤسسة حاليًا أو لا؟
بشكل مباشر، لا
ولكن نحن داعمين نقل المعرفة من الاتحاد إلى المؤسسة
دعم المؤسسة على أرض الواقع
راح تكون سنوية هي على عكس المعتاد في كؤوس العالم
لا المعتاد أن تكون..
لا المعتاد أقصد في كأس العالم لكرة القدم للمنتخبات أتذكر الأربع سنوات
الرياضات المختلفة في كثير رياضات كأس العالم يكون سنوي
هذا راح يكون سنوي
يمكن هنا سؤال يخص دوركم في الاتحاد والتزاماتكم في الاستراتيجية
هو موضوع عدد الأندية أنتم عليكم مستهدف 250 نادي صح؟
250 لعبة
الوصول إلى عدد عفوًا، 250 شركة ألعاب إلكترونية
شركة ألعاب غير شركة نادي
صحيح
أنتم اليوم هذا الهدف متى المفترض يتحقق؟
وإلى اليوم كم سوِّيتوا من شركة ألعاب؟
إذا تسمح لي أبو عبد الرحمن، ممكن أرجع للاستراتيجية
وعناصرها، وأقول لك أيش تحقق في كل جانب
الاستراتيجية الوطنية شملت أكثر من عنصر
صناعة الألعاب والرياضات الإلكترونية والتشريعات والدعم المادي
بالإضافة إلى دعم المواهب واستقطابها
بالنسبة لصناعة ألعاب الفيديو
تكلمنا عن «سافي» والحراك اللي قاعدة تسويه
بالإضافة إلى أنه فيه أكثر من مبادرة لدعم هذا الموضوع
اليوم، احنا أيش اللي نبيه في عالم ألعاب الفيديو؟
أنا شرحت لك المشهد، وعدد المستخدمين وعدد اللاعبين وكمية الساعات
النزيف الاقتصادي اللي قاعد يصير برَّى
أيش الأهداف؟
هذه الآلام الموجودة، ولكن الهدف أكبر بكثير من هذا الشيء
اليوم من خلال الألعاب الإلكترونية، وانتشارها المرعب على مستوى العالم
اليوم احنا ممكن نصدر ألعاب
اللي تحقق لنا أهداف اقتصادية واجتماعية
وبالإضافة إلى أن الألعاب الإلكترونية أكبر وأهم وسيلة إعلامية
فكمية العمق العربي والإسلامي الموجود عندك
وكمية القصص الملحمية التي لم تروى بالشكل المناسب إلى الآن
أنا ممكن أستخدم هذه المنصة لنشر ثقافتي
لنشر القصص والإرث الموجود عندي
على مستوى الرياضات الإلكترونية أعتقد أننا غطيناها بشكل كامل
بس عفوًا، قبلما نروح في الجزء الأول، تأسيس شركات تطور هذه الألعاب
أيش صار في هذا البند إلى الآن؟
على مستوى «سافي» كانت موجودة، وهي حاملة المشعل في هذا الموضوع
في شركات كثير
ماني شايف «سافي» تسوي شيء غير أنها تستحوذ
لا
فيه تطوير ألعاب قاعد يصير؟
صحيح، تطوير لعبة من ثلاث إلى سبع سنوات
الله يسلمك، تأسيس شركة عملاقة بحجم «سافي»
ما نعتقد الأثر حقها يكون خلال أشهر أو سنة أو سنتين
صناعة اللعبة من ثلاث إلى سبع سنوات
اليوم في حراك على مستوى صناعة الألعاب
على مستوى الاستثمار والنمو العضوي والغير عضوي
بالإضافة إلى دعم شركات سعودية، واستقطاب شركات عالمية
الهدف السامي
أن نصل إلى بيئة خصبة للاستثمار، ولصناعة الألعاب في السعودية
كل المبادرات تحاكي عن هذا الموضوع
هذه صناعة الألعاب، وتنظيم البطولات حكينا عنه، اللي بعده؟
التشريعات قبل إطلاق الاستراتيجية
بقيادة الأخوان في «جي كام» أو هيئة التنظيم الإعلامي
أكثر الألعاب وقنوات التواصل بيننا وبين الناشرين ما كانت في أفضل حالاتها
الألعاب ممكن أنها تحظر من السوق السعودي
المستخدم في الأخير يروح إلى أي سوق ثاني
اليوم فتحنا قنوات التواصل بقيادة خوادم الـ«جي كام»
وصار فيه طلب لـ...
بدأنا نوصل لمرحلة أن يجلسوا مع الناشرين
ويحجبون بعض المشاهد اللي عندنا تحفظ عليها
واللي ثقافتنا تحتم علينا هذا الشيء
فهذا في مصلحتنا ما هو بس على مستوى اقتصادي
حتى ثقافيًّا احنا مهتمين بهذا الموضوع
تسهيل دخول الناشرين هذول للسوق السعودي
إذا يبغوا يشتغلوا على موضوع التوطين
حتى موضوع التوطين على مستوى الألعاب الإلكترونية
ما هو بس أنك تجي، وتكون موجود، ما هو بس جانب اقتصادي
ولكن اللعبة ممكن يكون فيها خريطة سعودية
ممكن يكون فيها شخصية سعودية ممكن يكون فيها قصة معلم سعودي
هذا على مستوى التشريعات
على مستوى الدعم المادي، أبو عبد الرحمن، عندنا واحدة من المبادرات
بقيادة الأخوان في صندوق التنمية الوطني و«اجنايت»
صندوق تنموي خاص بدعم القطاع
اليوم تجاوزنا العشرين شركة اللي اندعمت بمبالغ أكثر من 150 مليون ريال
هو الظاهر خصصو لكم 300 مليون صح؟
حجم الصندوق 1.8 مليار
الصندوق إلى الآن ما تأسس
ولكن التوجه على ما يتأسس الصندوق راح نشغله ببرنامج حجمه 300 مليون
واليوم شغالين على رفعه لأنه قربنا
نصها صرفت 150 مليون راحت لعشرين شركة
صحيح
أيش نوع الشركات هذه؟
كلها تحاكي سلسلة التقييم الكاملة
فيه استيديوهات خاصة في تطوير الألعاب في شركات تنظيم
كلها شركات محلية؟
كلها شركات محلية
لا يكون كلها راحت «سافي»
لا، «سافي»
وصارت فلوس الحكومة
لا، «سافي» ما لها علاقة
برَّة الموضوع فهذه شركات قطاع خاص
100%
كلها شركات صغيرة، هذا على مستوى الجانب المالي
في جانب المواهب
جانب المواهب، واستقطاب القدرات
في مبادرات قيادة أخواننا في وزارة الاتصالات
وفيه الأكاديمية السعودية للرياضات الإلكترونية
على مستوى برنامج «إيجنايت» تحديدًا
كان فيه كثير من المبادرات اللي تخدم مطوري الألعاب
كيف تطور اللعبة من الأساسيات إلى أن توصل لنموذج كامل
مع أفضل المعاهد والمراكز العالمية
عندنا في الاتحاد عندنا الأكاديمية السعودية للرياضات الإلكترونية
هذه خرجنا فيها قرابة الألف لاعب هذه السنة
هذه الأكاديمية تبعكم؟
اي صحيح الخاصة بالـ«إي سبورت» تبعنا
فيه برامج كثيرة كيف تكون محترف في اللعبة الفلانية
وفيه برامج ما تحاكي بس الجانب الفني من اللاعب كيف تكون مدرب ممتاز
كيف تكون إداري ممتاز، وتجيب رعايات لناديك الإلكتروني
فنحاول أننا نثقف اللاعبين
وأكثر خريجين الأكاديمية خلال أشهر بسيطة
نلقاهم متعاقدين مع أندية سواءً كلاعب أو كإداري
سنويًّا كم تخرجون ألف؟
السنة هذه قرابة الألف
قرابة الألف
والتسجيل فيها برسوم في مقابل مادي لهذه الدورات؟
معظمها بدون رسوم وبعضها يكون في رسوم رمزية
أتوقع هذه فرصة حلوة جدًّا للأشخاص المهتمين في القطاع
أو اللي يبغوا يشوفوا فرصهم إذا هي مجانية
فأخذ دورة أتعلم مهارة الأندية موجودة تتعاقد معي
والبطولات جوائزها مغرية وواضحة
جدًّا
رحلة اللاعب وبناء الوظيفة على مستوى اللاعب
والمستهدف من ناحية الوظائف في الاستراتيجية
المستهدف أن نوصل إلى 39 ألف وظيفة في 2023
39 ألف وظيفة
فالقطاع هذا راح يوظف ويحرك الاقتصاد
وله مكاسب اجتماعية ومكأسب ثقافية كثيرة
39 ألف وظيفة هذه موزعة على القطاع بالأكمل
لفت نظري من ضمن مناصبك
العضو المنتدب وعضو مجلس إدارة شركة البنية التحتية للألعاب الإلكترونية
أيش الشركة هذي تبع «القدية»؟
هذه، الله يسلمك، تبع «سافي»
تبع «سافي»
هي شركة البنية التحتية الخاصة في..
أيش فرق هذه الشركة عن المضمار أو الحلبة الي تسويها «القدية»؟
شركة البنية التحتية أو شركة «القيمنج»
الفكرة منها أن يكون فيه سلسلة مراكز للألعاب الإلكترونية
لما أتكلم عن البنية التحتية وهنا ممكن أرجع من منظور استراتيجي
كلمة بنية تحتية بالألعاب الإلكترونية مهمة وحساسة
وهي أحد العناصر اللي أنا ما تكلمت عنها
أنا حسيت أن بس يبي إنترنت ومكيف
الإنترنت مهم إلى درجة يقاس «البينج» أو كم جزء من الثانية تأخر الاتصال عندك
إذا كان أكثر من 100 أكثر الألعاب تعتبر غير قابلة للعب
واحنا كنا أكثر من 100 في أكثر الألعاب
في قيادة زملاء بوزارة الاتصالات وهيئة الاتصالات
اشتغلنا على برامج كثيرة
على نوعين، نوع إجرائي أو تحفيز لشركات الاتصالات السعودية
والنوع الثاني هو خاص بالبنية التحتية والخوادم
قطعنا شوط كان فيه إنجازات كبيرة
نزلناها من 180 «البينج» إلى أربعين وثلاثين
فالطموح أن تكون تجربة اللاعب الأفضل على مستوى العالم
أننا نوصل قرابة العشرة
وهذه شغالين عليها، وقاطعين شوط
أن الخوادم تكون مستضافة في السعودية
فهذه الشركة تسوي مراكز للعب؟
مراكز ألعاب إلكترونية أرجع إلى شركة البنية التحتية
مراكز ألعاب إلكترونية تدعم...
اللي هي عبارة عن زي ما كنا نشوف في التسعينيات
تدخل مكان فيه أجهزة، وناس يلعبون، كذا؟
بالضبط
ولكن بمحاكاة اللي وين وصلنا اليوم
فهذه الشركة اللي أنت عضو منتدب فيها وتبع «سافي»
صحيح
و«الأرينا» أو اللي في «القدية»؟
اللي في «القدية» «أرينا» متعددة الاستخدام
الهدف أنه تستضيف كأس العالم في «القدية» بمجرد افتتاح «الأرينا»
فالبنية التحتية من ناحية «الأرينا»
ومن ناحية الأماكن هذا دور «القدية» معنا
في مجموعة أسئلة، أبو حصة، بمر عليها بعد إذنك
ممكن واحد من أهم الأسئلة، وهو له وجاهة كبيرة
أنتم أبعد ما يكون عن الرياضة هي عبارة عن عكس الرياضة والصحة
جلسة مطولة وقدام الشاشة، وما في حركة، وضغط عصبي
أنت تتكلم على كل اللي قاعدين نحاول نسويه
في برنامج التحول الصحي وبرنامج تحسين الصحة، أنتم تسوون عكسه
وكلما شجعتوا أكثر كلما زادت الساعات اللي تقضى في هذا الموضوع
كيف تتعاملون مع هذه الفكرة؟
هنا برضو جزء من مسؤولياتنا، الله يسلمك
أنه حتى على مستوى اللاعب المحترف
واحنا غالبًا نخاطب اللاعب المحترف
ما تعتقد أن اللاعب المحترف مطلوب منه أن يقعد ثمانية ساعات قدام الشاشة
هذا أكبر غلط
بالعكس، بالأساس الجهد الذهني الذي يبذله اللاعب عالي جدًّا
أنت على أساس تستمر لياقتك الذهنية عالية جدًّا
لمدة أربع أو ثلاث ساعات وهي مدة البطولات
لازم تكون لياقتك البدنية عالية على أساس يدعمك في عملية اتخاذ القرارات
لياقتي البدنية؟ اللياقة الذهنية قصدك
أنت عشان تحافظ على لياقتك الذهنية الأطول لوقت ممكن
لازم يكون عندك الحد الأدنى من اللياقة البدنية
الآن من خلال الدورات والدراسات احنا دورنا توعوي في هذا الموضوع
الموضوع هو تقنين
هل في أي ممارسات صحية؟
مثلاً اليوم أبسطها في مباريات كرة القدم اللي تُلعب في الصيف
اخترعوا أو حطوا لك استراحة إضافية في نص الشوط
يطلع اللاعب يشرب موية يتبرد، ويرجع لأنه خطورة الحرارة على صحته
واحنا نتكلم على واحد يقوم بمجهود بدني راح ينعكس إيجابًا عليه
فهل في أي ممارسات تحفظ الصحة تقاعدين تسوونها في بطولاتكم؟
طبعًا
أعطني مثال
مثلاً الجانب عندنا، الله يسلمك
الإخوان في مستشفى «مركز الملك سلمان» الشميسي
الزملاء في مركز «الشميسي»
نتعاقد معهم على الجانب اللياقي والثقافي
الحملات التوعوية الصحية لصحة اللاعب
لأفضل طرق الممارسة على مستوى الألعاب الإلكترونية هذا دورنا
توعية اللاعبين بالإضافة إلى أن البطولات ما تكون مدتها..
بس فيه ضوابط معينة؟ للمدة اللي يقضيها اللاعب
أو فترة الانتظار أي اشراطات لبعد الشاشة ما فيه ولا شيء
لا، ما فيه أي شيء دقيق
راميينها على «الشميسي» والله يقويهم
لا، هي رسائل توعوية
لا، التوعية عمرها ما غيرت شيء
رسائل توعوية
التوعية عمرها ما غيرت شيء
احنا نسمع عن المرور، لا تسرعون، من يوم الله خلقنا
ما هدِّينا إلا يوم شفنا «ساهر»
لما يصير في ضوابط واشتراطات، هذا دورك أنت كاتحاد
أنك أنت تحط ضوابط اليوم بالذات تتعامل مع فئة عمرية صغيرة
مستوى الوعي عندهم ما هو بالضرورة تعتمد عليه
صحيح، اليوم الاتحاد أنا مسؤول عن البطولات اللي أنا أمارسها
أيش ضوابطك في هذه البطولات؟
خلال البطولات هذه، يعني ما رح أسوي بطولة مدتها أربعة عشر ساعة
ما رح أسوي مباراة مدتها خمسة ساعات، ما رح أسوي كذا
ففيها الحد الأدنى الطبيعي على مستوى البطولات
اللي هو؟
مدة الشوط، اللاعب عندي ما راح يلعب إثنا عشر ساعة متواصلة، مستحيل
ممكن تكون في أكثر من مباراة بس على فريقين مختلفين
بس أقصد، أبو حصة، مثلًا في عالم الطيران
الطيار عنده ساعات معينة، إثنا عشر ساعة
بعدها لو يصير اللي يصير مستحيل يقود طيارة
فتلاحظ أحيانًا تصير مشاكل إذا تأخرت الطيارة في المدرج فجأة
غيروا الكابتن لأنه استنفذت إثنا عشر ساعة في موقع العمل
في أحيانًا ضوابط معينة صانع القطاع يصنعها لحفظ هذا الإنسان
رغم أنهم كبار سن، وناضجين ومهنيين
فما بالك بفئة عمرية أصغر ربما يكون عندها هذا المعيار الداخلي أقل
بس أنا ما سمعت منك ولا معيار أنتو شغالين عليه
جميل، أنا أعتقد عمر القطاع صغير، ما هو بس عندنا، عالميًّا
وأتوقع أنه هذه فرصة للتحسين ممكن ننظر لها
والله أوصي بذلك
سؤال تكرر كثير، وأنا مو بعادتي أتصيد
لكن لأن هذا تكرر كثير جدًّا، أحس لازم أطرحه
كمية الشكاوي من سوء التنظيم في بطولاتكم
تمثل نصف عدد الأسئلة اللي جاءتنا
ولا هي لبطولة واحدة طبعًا هم تكلموا كثير عن موضوع ببجي
لكن يتكلمون عن كل بطولاتكم
ويتكلمون على مدار أربع سنوات، وليس عن حالة محددة
كيف رضاك على التنظيم؟
أنا فخور بالمرحلة...
ياويلك منهم
اللي وصلنا لها من التنظيم
أنا باجي للموضوع هذا، وزين أنك تطرقت له
مستوى التنظيم اليوم اللي احنا واصلين له في السعودية
يارب لك الحمد، يشرف، وأنا فخور بالمستوى اللي احنا وصلنا له
هل وصلنا لمرحلة الكمال؟ لا، أكيد في مجال للتحسين
بطولة ببجي صارت حادثة، وزعلت جزء كبير من الجمهور
لخطأ خلينا نقول أو لعاطفة جماهيرية
الجمهور كان عندهم توقع معين اللي صار عكس توقعهم
النادي كان عنده خيار أنه يروح بشكل مباشرة يتخاطب مع الاتحاد
يطلع بيان
هو طلع بيان إعلامي نشره للعامة، وهذا يخالف لائحة الانضباط
الجميل في الحوكمة، أبو عبد الرحمن
أنه اليوم عندنا الدوري السعودي الإلكتروني
وفيه الاتحاد ولجان قضائية مستقلة ممثلة بلجنة الانضباط ولجنة الاستئناف
احنا كاتحاد، أحيانًا يفرضون عقوبات عن الاتحاد
أحيانًا النادي إذا كان عنده حق، وراح للجنة هذه لجنة قضائية مستقلة
فاللي صار فعلًا لجنة الانضباط طلعت قرارها
وقرارها تم إشهاره بناءً على طلبهم، بناءً على القرار نفسه
واحنا لازم اننا ننشر القرار هذا
فرسالتي لكل الأندية وكل الجماهير
أن نكون واعيين باللوائح الخاصة بالدوري واللوائح الخاصة باللجان
سواءً للانضباط أو الاستئناف لأنها مهمة جدًّا
اليوم فيه إجراء لازم نتبعه عشان نأخذ..
أو هي الطريقة المناسبة للاحتجاج والاعتراض
الغريب أنهم يتكلمون هم يتكلمون على موضوع أنه فيه فرق نقطتين
أنا بعيد فقاعد أحاول أفهم
يتكلمون أن فيه فرق نقطتين وكان فيه فريق متقدم اللي هو «آر إيت»
كانوا همه متقدمين، وبعدين فجأة اكتشفوا أنهم لا هم متأخرين
فأنا فهمي دائمًا أن الإنسان مأسور لمعرفته
فأنا قاعد أتخيل أنه الهلال والاتحاد في الدوري
طول الموسم الاتحاد هو المتقدم بثلاث نقاط
فجأة تيجي آخر المباراة تقول: نسينا ثلاث نقاط للهلال
فالهلال صار هو المتقدم
بالنسبة لي المشهد ما هو مفهوم
شلون في آخر دقيقة تكتشفون أن في نقطتين مفقودة أو زائدة؟
ممتاز، هنا ممكن أن أكثر الانتقاد جاي على التنظيم
ولكن في الـ«إي سبورت»
التنظيم والتحكيم هما تقريبًا وجهين لعملة واحدة
فممكن يقصدون التحكيم، ويتكلمون عن التنظيم
أو كلمة حكم عندنا على مستوى الـ«إي سبورت» ما هي موجودة دائمًا
منظم
أي
فهذه شغلة
البطولة اللي صارت نظامها أن النتيجة النهائية تعلن
يعني ما تقدر أنت تشوف الهلال والاتحاد كم سجل هدف، وأنت تعرف
لا، هي تعلن في نهاية المباراة
أكثر من شوط يلعبون، وكل شوط الفريق يجمع نقاط
وفي النهائي الفريق اللي جاب أكثر النقاط هو اللي يكسب
صار فيه خطأ في احتساب عدد النقاط
النادي نشر توقعاته قبل
الخطأ صار من مين؟
خطأ الاحتساب صار من مين؟
نادي «آر إيت» نشر النتيجة المتوقعة قبل الإعلان الرسمي من المنظم
وهذا اللي صار في خلاف التوقعات بين المنظم والنادي وجمهور النادي
اللي يخليني برضو أشوف أنها ما هي بس مشكلتها الحدث هذا
أيضًا في أسئلة على موضوع جودة النقل والإنتاج
أنها لا توازي الطموح وضعيفة جدًّا مقارنة بالدول الأخرى
أيش رأيك على جودة الإنتاج والنقل؟
بالعكس
اليوم، عمر، أنا أفهم الغضب العاطفي الموجود من هذا الجمهور
أفهم تمامًا هم من وين جايين
اليوم احنا واصلين مراحل جدًّا ممتازة
على مستوى الدوري السعودي
حتى ودوري الجامعات جودة النقل اللي فيه
بالنسبة إلى بطولة على هذا الحجم وهذا المستوى تعتبر جودة مقبولة جدًّا
بس كيف أخرج من هذا الجدل، أيش المرجع؟
هم يقولوا سيء، وأنت تقول كويس، مين الحكم وأيش المرجع؟
هل في معايير معين أو هل في تصنيف معين للنقل؟ أنا ما فهمت
ممتاز، ممكن أن نسأل شخص محايد
لا، أقصد مثلًا...
ولجنة محايدة
في الدوري السعودية يقولون لك «أس أس سي» جودتها ما هي زي «بي إن»
أبغى أتكلم شوية فنيًّا، اليوم الدوري الإنقليزي
في أفضل مباريات في ثمانية كاميرات تنقل
وفي أقل المباريات في كاميرا واحدة تنقل
هو من أفضل البطولات
هذا وين يقام؟
وأكثر متابعة، الدوري البريطاني
الدوري السعودي الإلكتروني نتجاوز الأربعة وعشرين كاميرا
على مستوى الأستوديو
ونفس جودة الكاميرات؟
المقياس جدًّا كبير فيه كاميرا على كل لاعب، ولها جودة معينة
وفي كاميرات موزعة على مستوى «الأرينا» والاستيديو
فالإنتاج مختلف تمامًا
تعقيد بث ونقل بطولة خاصة بالـ«إي سبورت» مختلفة تمامًا
وأصعب من أي رياضة ثانية
ولكن مع ذلك احنا واصلين مرحلة ما هي سهلة أبدًا
في سؤال على دور الاتحاد في الوقوف مع لاعب المنتخب السعودي «يزن»
اللي مُنع في لعبة «أوفرواتش» من المشاركة في كأس العالم
ما أدري أيش السالفة، بس قاعد أنقل
هذا من أهم الأدوار اللي يقوم فيها الاتحاد مع اللاعبين بشكل عام
اليوم احنا نحفز اللاعبين، وهذا واجبنا
أيش القصة؟
تشريف السعودية في المحافل الدولية
فكثير من اللاعبين يصير عندهم تحديات مع  الناشرين وبطرق مختلفة تمامًا
«يزن»، يعطيه العافية، من أفضل اللاعبين الموجودين عندنا
وقاعدين نحاول ندعمه مع الناشر في كل البطولات اللي هو يشاركها
هو ومجموعة من اللاعبين
في الموقف هذا تحديدًا لما منع في هذه البطولة، أيش سويتوا؟
احنا علاقتنا استراتيجية مع كل الناشرين
نحاول أننا نذلل كل المشاكل
دخلنا في الكلام الدبلوماسي، صار الكلام كله دبلوماسي
في سؤال واضح، لاعب أوقف في «أوفرواتش» سويتوا له شيء وللا لا؟
احنا نتفاوض
اه لسه الموضوع الآن صاير؟
قاعدين نضغط على الناشر أنه يكون الجزء من الموضوع
ليش ما سُمح له يلعب؟
هذه قاعدين نشوفها مع الناشر
هل ممكن نشوف تخصص صناعة ألعاب الفيديو في الجامعات السعودية؟
صحيح، بإذن الله، هذه أحد الأشياء اللي احنا نطمح لها
البرامج التعليمية الموجودة هي قصيرة
ولكن احنا نطمح لأنه يكون عندنا دبلوم
ونطمح أنه يكون عندنا بكالوريوس خاص بألعاب الفيديو
اشتغلتوا مع أي من الجامعات، بدأتوا مع أحد ولا لسه؟
في عندنا عروض من عدة جامعات كلها تحت الدراسة
ما في شيء حتى الآن
فيه كلام على إفلاس أندية كثيرة، واستحوذات بمبالغ بخسة
متابع أنت أيش قاعد يصير في الأندية؟ الموجة الأولى
اليوم مشهد الرياضات الإلكترونية، وأندية الرياضات الإلكترونية تحديدًا
زي ما قلت لك أبو عبد الرحمن، كلها شركات
فهم عبارة عن لاعبين، وعندهم حس ريادي، أسسوا شركات وفرق
فالتحديات التي تواجه الناشئين هي تحديات تواجه...
أي ناشئ
فطبيعة الحال هو عالي المخاطر راح يكون
الحزم الموجودة عندنا التعليمية والتثقيفية والتوعوية نحاول أن نكثفها
على أساس نزيد قصص النجاح بين الأندية
وغير التوعية من الأشياء اللي كانت تتسوى في أندية المحترفين
موضوع اشتراطات الحوكمة عشان تحصل على دعم
صحيح
نوع من التحفيز لتزبط أمورك
هل في شيء زي كذا قاعد يصير مع الأندية؟
اليوم واحدة من المبادرات ندنا دعم الأندية
نشترط على الأندية حد أدنى من الحوكمة
عشان يستلم دعم مادي معين
وكلما رفع الحوكمة الموجودة عند النادي كلما زادت حصصه
أو زادت فرصة أن يأخذ دعم مادي أكبر
تعطون دعم مادي للأندية؟
صحيح
أيش الحد الأدنى اللي لو أنا أسست نادي مضمون راح أخذ الرقم؟
تقريبًا 50 ألف، ويوصل إلى 300 ألف
على حسب أدائي والتزامي بالحوكمة
صحيح
أرقام جيدة
هنا سؤال على جوائز بطولة فيفا
اللي فاز فيها فريق الاتحاد في فبراير، 2020
عرفتها البطولة؟
جوائز؟
في فبراير، 2020 سويتوا أنتم جوائز بطولة فيفا
يبدو أنها الدوري الموازي للدوري
اللي هي الأندية الاتحاد والهلال، تذكرت البطولة؟
أعتقد
فيقول أول بطولة في العالم ما تكون الجوائز واضحة من أول يوم
قالوا أن فيه جوائز بالملايين، ويوم انتهت البطولة سلموهم 30 ألف
هذه البطولة فعلًا احنا ما أعلنَّا عن جوائزها وقت الإعلان
ولكن أعلنَّا عن الجوائز قبلما تبدأ البطولة، وهذه مع الأندية كاملة
يعني قبلما تلعب أول مباراة، الجوائز معلنة؟
تم الإعلان عنها، إي
وهذه البطولة كانت بطولة أندية الحكومية اللي هي الهلال والنصر
والجوائز كانت تروح للنادي
النادي كيف يتعاقد مع اللاعب؟ هذا موضوع مختلف تمامًا
صح
بس هم يقولون أنتم أعلنتوا جوائز مليونية، وفي الواقع ما كانت مليونية
كانت الجوائز مليون ريال
مجموعها؟
مجموع الجوائز بشكل كامل مليون ريال
واحد يسأل عن هل البطولات مناطقية؟
جاوبنا عليها أنت تقول تصفيات مفتوحة للجميع
ما فيها شيء يخص المناطق
واحد عتبان عليك، يقول قبل فترة ظهر في إحدى مساحات منصة إكس
وقال أن أبوابهم مفتوحة للمبادرات الصغيرة والكبيرة
وتواصلت معهم، وما أحد رد علي
كيف تواصل؟
ما أعرف، يمكن منشن ولا رسالة، أيش وسيلة التواصل المفضلة لكم؟
الإيميل الرسمي أو الموقع الرسمي
من خلاله اللي يبي يقدم على وظيفة أو يسجل كمساهم موجود
التواصل المباشر مع الاتحاد إذا أحد عنده حالة مشروع معينة ممكن أنه يجتمع
فعلًا كل بوابنا مفتوحة
هذا يسأل يقول: ليش أغلب فرق الرياضات الإلكترونية
لا تمت للرياضة بأي صلة
أشهر الفرق محتواها عبارة عن مقالب وتحديات
عكس الفرق الإلكترونية في الخارج؟
صحيحة هذه الملاحظة؟ ترى ما أدري
الناس تخلط بين فرق الرياضات الإلكترونية وفِرق المحتوى
الرياضات الإلكترونية حتى لو كان المحتوى خاص بألعاب الفيديو
مو معناها أنها رياضة إلكترونية
فرق الرياضات الإلكترونية هي فرق تنافسية
تشارك في بطولات وواضح مسارها
وفي فرق ثانية أو فرق لإنتاج المحتوى
يصير عندها مسارات مختلفة تمامًا
وعلى طاري المحتوى جزء من فضولي
قلت هذا عالم ملايين وأرقام وهبال
دخلت على قناتكم في اليوتيوب
المشاهدات 300 و500 و600 مشاهدة للفيديو الواحد، ففي مشكلة
وين الأرقام اللي تقولون عنها؟
المشكلة في المنصة، أبو عبد الرحمن
الله يسلمك، المنصة الرسمية للرياضات الإلكترونية هي «تويتش»
فأكثر المشاهدات تكون من خلال منصة «تويتش»
هي الأرقام اللي قلت لك المليونية والمليارية
كلها هناك
غالبًا أنها تكون على «تويتش»
وأتذكر «عمر» كان يقول لنا أنه في جهة مستقلة تجي وتدقق
وتتثبت من الأرقام هذه لأنها يبنى عليها رعايات، ويبنى عليها أشياء كثيرة
صحيح
فأنتم تسوون تنسيق مع الجهات؟
صحيح، كل الأرقام اللي نتكلم فيها من ناحية عدد المشاهدات وغيره
هذه ما هي أرقام من تقارير خاصة بالاتحاد
لا، في جهة مستقلة هي تطلع الأرقام هذه
وخصوصًا التعامل مع الرعاة
يفضلون أن يكون في جهة مستقلة هي تطلع الأرقام والتحاليل هذه
السؤال قبل الأخير
واحد يتكلم على أنه ما هو مقتنع إطلاقًا بطريقة الاستثمارات حقت «سافي»
أنت ما تمثل «سافي»
لكن هو يتكلم على أيش الفكرة
بأنك تحط 5 مليار دولار في شركة «نينتندو»؟
هي شركة مدرجة تقدر تأخذ بياناتها ومعلوماتها مباشرة
أو تتعاقد معها بشكل مباشر، وتأخذ اللي تبيه
أيش القيمة من الاستحواذ على شركات عملاقة
لا تمثل حصصنا فيها إلا أشياء بسيطة؟
هي شراكات استراتيجية، أبو عبد الرحمن
أقدر أسويها بدون ما أستثمر
ما تقدر تطلب عضوية مجلس إدارة، وأنت برة الشركة
صرت عضو، عندي صوت واحد
ما تقدر تأخذ الشراكة هذه إلى مكان مختلف
ما تقدر تنقل توطيين معرفة بدون شراكات استراتيجية حقيقية
بالإضافة إلى الجانب المادي
سعر الاستحواذ، ومقارنةً بقيمته اليوم دخَّل عائد ما دخَّله استثمارات ثانية
فهذا مكسب سريع واضح
هذا فرضيًّا ولا واقع؟
هذا واقع
قيمة السهم اليوم مقارنةً بقيمة الاستحواذ مختلفة، ونمت مبلغ وقدره
هذا مكسب سريع واضح، بس الهدف الاستراتيجي من هذه الاستحواذات
هو هدف يصب في توجه وأحداث استراتيجية
وتواجدنا بشكل عام في هذا القطاع
على الطاري يمكن واضح هذه الاستحواذات من «سافي»
لأنه هذا تخصصها
بس مو مفهوم ليش «مسك» تستحوذ على شركة ألعاب رقمية
عندك تصور؟
«مسك» عندهم توجهات في صناعة المحتوى والشباب
ما أعتقد أنه عندي تصور واضح بالنسبة لهم، ولكن على تواصل معهم
واحنا كلنا نكمل بعض بشكله أو بآخر
سؤالي الأخير، لو في شخص إلى الآن، بعد ساعة ونص من الحلقة
ما اقتنع أنه كل هذا القطاع فيه شيء يستاهل
أن ينحط عليه هذه الفلوس والجهد، أيش تبي تقول له؟
أنا أعتقد أن الزيارة هي اللي تخلي أي شخص يتغير
أنا على المستوى الشخصي عائلتي ما هم مستوعبين اللي أنا قاعد أسويه
وهذا شيء موجود يعني ولا أقدر ألومهم
لأنه بالنسبة لهم هذا عالم موازي ما يفهمون عنه ولا شيء
وغير متقبلين أنهم يسمعون أي شيء عن هذا العالم
أنا أخذت موسم «القيمرز» فرصة أني دعيت عائلتي على أساس يستوعبون
أيش ألعاب الفيديو وأيش الألعاب الإلكترونية؟
وأيش اللي يحدث في هذا العالم؟
ومن خلال هذه الزيارة استوعبوا، على الأقل الحد الأدنى
من حجم الحراك اللي قاعد يصير، وحجم الأثر الموجود
المُشاهدة خير دليل
إذا كان هناك شخص ما هو مستوعب، أبدًا ما ألومه
أقرب الناس لي ما كانوا مستوعبين، وأتفهم هذا الشيء
ولكن أتمنى أن يكونوا ضيوف عندنا في الفعاليات والبطولات الخاصة فينا
وابدأ فيني أنا
هذه دعوة
كأس العالم، إن شاء الله، في يوليو أحتاج أجي أشوف بنفسي
وأستوعب هذا العالم
لهذه الدرجة يستاهل هذا الاهتمام أو لا؟
تشرفنا
تسلم، شكرًا يا أبو حصة، شرفتنا ونورتنا
شكرًا
الله يحييك
يعطيك العافية
شكرًا لكم
شكرًا لفهد القصير في إعداد وإنتاج هذه الحلقة
في التحرير: أنس الخليل
في الإخراج الإبداعي:فؤاد الهتلان
إدارة التصوير: عبد الرحمن خالد
في الإضاءة: إسماعيل شوقي
في تسجيل الصوت: يوسف إبراهيم
وفي الهندسة الصوتية: عبد العزيز المزي
وفي إدارة الإنتاج: عبد المجيد عمر
وفي الإشراف على الإنتاج: رزان دهيثم
هذا بودكاست سقراط، أحد منتجات شركة تمانية للنشر والتوزيع